Google has opened a new front in its
battle with Apple for the smartphone and
tablet Market
smartphone War have just got more
interesting Google's now going to become
a manufacturer
remember Motorola at one point they were
selling Network equipment signal
amplifiers and even digital video
recorders but likely the product that
they're most well known for is their
cell phones and particularly this one
the Motorola Razer back in the early
2000s this phone was ubiquitous and you
can't forget about the nostalgic
ringtone either there was something
about the Sleek look of the phone and
the premium build that people just
couldn't get enough of you could even
argue that it was the status symbol of
the time given that it wasn't cheap
having launched for 500 or the price of
the original iPhone nonetheless Motorola
went on to sell 130 million units during
their Heyday and to this day the only
iPhone that has sold better is the
iPhone 6 and 6 Plus as a combination the
bad part about the Razer for Motorola
was that it was basically a one-hit
wonder while they did have a substantial
business outside of cell phones their
cell phone business was what was really
iconic and as we saw the introduction of
blackberries and smartphones Motorola
phones quickly fell out of favor they
did try to Pivot to the smartphone
market themselves but this wasn't all
that successful and that brings us to
early 2011. to most it seemed obvious
that Motorola was on their way out and
that their fate was similar to that of
blackberry yet there was one person
willing to take a gamble on Motorola
Google in August of 2011 Google agreed
to pay 12.5 billion dollars in cash to
Prior the waning company as you would
have guessed critics and investors were
rather skeptical with many predicting
that it would be a colossal disaster and
as fate would have it that's exactly
what happened at least on paper less
than three years after the purchase
Google would end up selling Motorola to
Lenovo for just 2.9 billion dollars on
paper this was clearly a massive loss
having cost Google 9.6 billion dollars
plus the cost of running Motorola time
it would clear that Motorola was a
gargantuan mistake that only Google
could afford to make and there were
several similar articles mocking Google
for their seemingly apparent
incompetency but with time people
started to see a different side of the
picture and realized what game Google
was really playing so here's the story
of Google's worst acquisition that
actually turned out to be their best
hearing that Motorola may have been
Google's best acquisition is probably
hard to believe at first glance after
all Google has had so many successful
Acquisitions and the most would point to
YouTube or Android as being Google's
best acquisition especially given that
both of them cost substantially less
than Motorola but the thing to note is
that Motorola actually played a massive
role in Android success and to really
understand this we'll have to take a
look back at the origins of Android the
story starts in October of 2003 well
before the launch of the iPhone at the
time Android wasn't even being developed
for smartphones it was actually being
developed for digital cameras but the
founders quickly realized that the
smartphone space had way more growth
potential and they would pivot which
attracted the interest of Larry Page of
Google Paige could see that the mobile
industry was gaining a lot of steam and
he wanted Google to be very much
involved but Google and Android had one
major problem they didn't have any
hardware neither of them had any
experience building any hardware and
while they tried it became clear very
early on that they wouldn't be able to
compete with Apple after the iPhone
announcement rather the focus of Android
had to be about how it could power
thousands of different phones unlike
apple and to make this a reality Google
needed phone manufacturers on board Q
and the open-handed alliance in November
2007. this Alliance connected Network
operators software developers and
component manufacturers and device
manufacturers who would all support and
embrace Android as you might have
guessed one of the device manufacturers
on board was Motorola the Motorola Droid
would have become the first phone that
ran Android 2.0 out of the box but they
were by no means the last all of
Google's partners would launch phone
after phone running Android and given
that these phones were generally cheaper
and more customizable than their apple
counterparts many would choose Android
and by 2010 Android would overtake iOS
in terms of total installations
meanwhile Google was pumping out update
after update as there were simply so
many features to add and eventually they
would even come out with their own
smartphone the Google Nexus but on
Android was a massive success in terms
of adoption and popularity there were
two massive clouds looming over the
project apple and Microsoft these two
had to dominated the OS space for
decades on the computer side of things
and that they very much wanted to extend
this Monopoly into the mobile space so
they would leverage all the patents they
had accumulated over the decades and
starts doing the hell up out of Google
Google didn't really have an easy way
out of these lawsuits the truth was that
Google probably was infringing on a
bunch of patents from Apple and
Microsoft and the fact that Android was
open source just made it easier for
these companies to scour through the
code and pinpoint infringements which is
exactly what they did this quote from
Steve Jobs is probably all you need to
understand Apple's tense on the
situation I will spend my last dying
breath if I need to it and I will spend
every penny of Apple's 40 billion
dollars in the bank to right this wrong
I'm going to destroy Android because
it's a stolen product I'm willing to go
through my nuclear war on this while
Microsoft approached the situation more
professionally I'm sure they had similar
beliefs internally given that they would
also Sue Google at first Google and
their Partners tried to counters who
apple and Microsoft after all and it's
not like they didn't have resources
themselves but this didn't turn out all
that favorably for them as juries would
start ruling against them take Apple's
case against Samsung for example the
jury ended up awarding Apple 1.049
billion dollars in Damages meanwhile
Samsung's counter lawsuit was awarded
zero dollars in Damages this was a
massive win for apple apple won more
money from Samsung than Equifax had to
pay for leaking the social security
numbers of 140 million people that's
definitely quite messed up but Google
wasn't even worried about the financial
consequences if apple or Microsoft were
willing to settle for 5 or 10 billion
dollars Google probably would have taken
the deal but the problem was that apple
and Microsoft didn't care about the cash
either they had plenty of cash
themselves they were in it for the
market share their goal was to shut down
Android by suing Google and given that
courts were starting to side with apple
this made Google very nervous Steve Jobs
wasn't willing to be in the middle so
Google only had one option Fight Fire
with Fire instead of focusing on how
they could defend Android Google would
shift their focus onto how they could
attack Apple and very quickly one option
became it very clear you see it while
Apple was creating all this commotion
about Google ripping up iOS with Android
they themselves had a history of ripping
off other companies and were dealing
with lawsuits themselves one company
that had a bunch of dirt on Apple was
Motorola over the years they had
accumulated 17 000 patents relating to
Wireless Communications networks
antennas Cellular Communications and who
knows what else they also had 7 500
patents pending on top of this Motorola
was already suing Apple on several
fronts and they were winning one Victory
even allowed them to prevent Apple from
selling iPhones in Germany until they
removed a Wireless feature from their
phone for Google this was a grand slam
and they were willing to pay any
monetary price
foreign
knew what Google was trying to do it and
they weren't exactly against it the
truth was while they were pulling off
some victories against Apple her
business was dying it and that they were
very much ready to cash out they knew
their worth though and it played
Hardball with Google at first Google was
looking to buy the company for high 20
dollars per share but Motorola would
work them up to 40 per share this was
way more than the business was worth and
that's why Google received so much heat
for this but as we discussed Google
couldn't care less about Motorola's
business they were interested in their
intellectual property and this is what
they would keep when Google sold
Motorola de Lenovo they would keep all
but 2000 patents and this is when Apple
and Microsoft finally realized that
Google wasn't gonna let go either just
three months after Google saw the
remains of Motorola Apple would settle
with Google and the duo would agree to
drop all patent litigations against each
other Microsoft would hold out for quite
a bit longer but they too would
eventually come to their senses if
Google was able to just save Android by
flipping Motorola for a 9.6 billion
dollar loss that itself would have been
worth it to given that Android is now
the most popular operating system in the
entire world but it gets even better for
Google you see it the 2.91 billion sale
to Lenovo wasn't the only sale that
Google was able to make with Motorola
they were also able to sell Motorola
set-top box unit to errors for 2.35
billion dollars reducing their total
loss to 7.24 billion but it doesn't stop
right there either right after Google
bought Motorola they were able to roll
over a bunch of Motorola's previous
losses onto their financial statement
yielding them a tax benefit of 6.6
billion dollars so really Google's total
out-of-pocket cost acquire Motorola's
entire patent library and defend Android
with a mere 640 million dollars for
perspective Google made about 79 billion
dollars in the last 12 month period so
the whole Motorola ordeal cost them in
just three days worth of net income not
to mention it they got to keep 22 500
patents and applications which works out
to less than twenty nine thousand
dollars per patent they can use these
patents to not only develop new devices
and Technologies but they can use them
to defend the company and even go on the
offensive
in the end all the Motorola Acquisitions
seem stupid at the time given the
company's fundamentals there was clearly
more to it than just that Google
brilliantly leveraged Motorola's
extensive patent library to protect one
of their biggest assets Android and they
didn't end up paying all that much out
of pocket either at the end of the day
critics argued that Google likely could
have defended Android even without
Motorola while Apple was making some
progress against Android it's unlikely
that Apple would have just been able to
shut down Android altogether so maybe
the better play was to just let Apple
play their games and eventually settle
in court but that likely would have been
a lot more expensive Apple was able to
win one billion dollars from Samsung
imagine how much they might have been
able to win it against the Google not to
mention it Google wouldn't have acquired
an arsenal of patents for dirt cheap
prices if they went that route now you
could definitely argue that Android
itself was a better acquisition because
if they hadn't bought Android there
would have been nothing to protect in
the first place and while that is true
Motorola remains their biggest
acquisition to this day and it's by far
their most underrated and strategic and
that makes Motorola Google's most
interesting acquisition for me but
that's just what I think did you know
about this massive war between apple
Google and Microsoft comment that down
below also drop a like if you're a fan
of Open Source software and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community it suggests for the video
ideas and then consider subscribing to
see more questions actually answered but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one